well Jamie she is a former deputy
assistant Secretary General for emerging
security challenges at NATO and an
associate fellow at Chatham House and
he's in London for us live so thank you
very much indeed for being with us
Charles Stratford was reporting to us
there that he'd been speaking to
Ukrainian soldiers who were saying that
they were going to exploit the chaos
they said and push towards uh Bach moot
but this seems to have taken the
ukrainians by surprise as much as it
appears to have done the Russians will
are the ukrainians in a position to be
able to take advantage of this if they
choose to
well they certainly are going to try to
to do that but of course a lot depends
on what plays out in Russia over the
next few hours and days and the extents
of which progressing having sort of
started this Mutiny institution calls it
is really able to sort of turn it into
an effective result for example pushing
up as the he seems to be doing uh
against Moscow may be persuading more uh
of the Russian army to Desert to his
cause there's no sign of that uh
happening at the moment maybe ringing
some major concessions out of Putin in
terms of sacking the defense minister
shoigu or garasimov the chief of the
general staff so uh I think you know it
really would have to achieve uh
pragosan's actions a much greater
Dimension to really give the ukrainians
a massive boost let's you know keep our
feet on the ground the Russians still
have 390 000 troops uh in Ukraine which
is in an enormous number they're well
dug in uh defensively and the Russians
would need to really transfer quite
significant numbers of troops for
example their paratroopers out of
Ukraine to go and deal with progosin to
leave a big hole in the Russian lines if
getting progression has been alleging
that his Fighters have been fired on by
the the Russian military the leader of
the Chechen fighters who are also part
of the Russian forces I said that
they're going to take action against
Wagner if if it's required if this
becomes a prolonged internal conflict
and let's not forget that Wagner
Fighters are tough guys who've been
fighting for several months on the front
lines in Ukraine if this lasts for
longer what kind of impact would an
unstable Russia have within Europe but
also worldwide
well well certainly we're seeing
increasing signs that the Ukrainian
conflict is bringing the chickens home
to Rooster back in Russia itself even
before uh the sort of uh opposition of
of pragosan uh to uh the Russian uh High
command that you had the sort of shadowy
uh Russian groups Allied to Ukraine
carrying out sabotage operations around
rostov on the Dawn and just over over
the border so this was already having a
destabilizing influence but again I
think we really have to keep our feet on
the on the ground here uh progressing
according to estimates doesn't have an
awful lot of soldiers yes you're right
in saying their battle will hardened but
whereas he started the war with 50 000
uh by most uh ex experts he's now down
to about 10 000 maybe a few more can you
really take on the Russian army and the
Kremlin uh with just that number
particularly as I say if over the next
few hours he doesn't rally a lot of the
Russian army to his cause and the
Russian commanders so far according to
to what they've said to the media have
been firmly on the side of Putin calling
on a brigosian to stop and indeed
integrate his uh Wagner organization as
they've been calling on him to do for a
long time into the Russian arm uh forces
a lot of the pragosians troops are in
fact held in Africa in the Central
African Republic in Mali in these
operations which have suited the
kremlin's covert operations in Libya and
I don't think pragosan is going to be
able to sort of bring those back to
Russia anytime soon to support him so I
think we have to keep a good sense of
perspective here this is clearly an
embarrassment for Putin it's clearly
going to weaken him uh uh of course it's
clearly going to make it harder for
Russia to pursue any counter-offensive
of its own in Ukraine particularly in
the weeks ahead but whether progressing
is able really to topple the existing
leadership is something where I still
have my own personal doubts you
mentioned before that the spread of of
uh Wagner troops around the the world
the world Syria Mali Libya Central
African Republic in Sudan if pragosan
goes what do you think is going to
happen to the structure of Wagner given
the fact as you were talking about that
Russia regards Wagner as very much its
own presence in those countries
yes indeed I think this is really the
right question because uh Putin and
progressing have tried to avoid
criticizing each other throughout this
sort of controversy which has been going
on between precaution and the Russian
commanders for some uh months now uh uh
pragosan is very much the creation of
Putin who has found him to be a highly
useful instrument to carry out for
example disinformation attacks against
the United States elections as ricosin
as admitted uh to have these incursions
into Africa which give the Russia the
Russian State affected the deniability
while bringing in enormous economic
benefits to Russia in terms of diamonds
and illegal Mining and or all of that
and at the same time of course uh one in
four of the Russian forces fighting in
back moot where the Russians have had
the biggest success during the winter
have come from Wagner so it's going to
be very difficult I think for Putin to
sort of get rid of Wagner because it's
been so helpful to him but on the other
hand for a coaching sort of rebellion
now May able to push Putin into a corner
where he may have to sacrifice of Wagner
in order to regain total control of the
over the Russian military but knowing
that in the process he stands a lot to
lose because uh pocosin has also been a
useful instrument to put in in terms of
dividing the Russian military and giving
him greater control himself so whether
he could still keep precaution on by
carrying out the negotiation which gives
precosin something of what he wants some
precaution as a result decides to stand
down uh and to uh uh uh remove his sort
of occupation of Russian military
facilities in rostov or whether Putin
now thinks that you know a split is
necessary and he has to crush right now
I think that's what we're going to learn
over the next 24 hours really
interesting to get your thoughts on this
Jimmy Shea as always thank you very much
indeed for being with us on Al Jazeera
thank you